today it's my pleasure to introduce our
speaker Robert Schulman Bob Schulman is
the sterling professor emeritus of
molecular biology and biophysics and
biochemical ER biophysics and
biochemistry and senior research
scientists in diagnostic radiology at
the magnetic resonance imaging center
here at Yale and at the Yale Medical
School professor Schulman got his
undergraduate degree from Columbia and
after serving in the Navy returned to
Columbia for a PhD in chemistry they
worked for many years at bell labs in in
condensed matter physics and electronics
and in the mid-1960s bob became
interested both in biochemistry and in
the question that had motivates today's
talk the function of the brain and and
human cognition he spent a sort of
transformative sabbatical doing research
with Francis Crick at the Cavendish labs
in Cambridge University and that which
intensified this new direction in in
biochemistry and biophysics bob joined
the faculty here in mb mb at yale in
1979 where he continued this
extraordinarily productive and
distinguished career and throughout that
time he's shown a notable interest in
the full intellectual breadth of what
yale university has to offer and was
actively involved and deeply engaged
with the wit humor a center when it was
begun here at yale some years ago indeed
a few years ago when a lecture series
and course in interdisciplinary work
between the sciences and the humanities
was created it was named in honor of bob
and so we have the robert schulman
series which is a course given at least
once a year that brings in outside
speakers who engage with a class a
seminar class that is hot with the
combination of science and humanities
content so today's program was
instigated with conversations that Bob
and I started over last spring and
summer instigated by the publication of
his new book just out earlier this year
brain imaging what it can and
tell us about consciousness published
earlier this year at Oxford University
Press the book is an impassioned and
every Titanic lactic description of the
strengths and weaknesses of this highly
successful and highly influential
science of functional brain imaging so
therefore a lot like Bob and a real a
real a real product of the author bob
has been actively participating in the
development of this technology and in
its application to to to to human brain
function in recent years but his own
scientific views and have led them to a
distinctive and strongly supported view
the limitations of functional brain
imaging science most interesting Bart
argues in the book for a critical
relationship between philosophy and
particularly metaphysics of basically
the classic mind-body problem and its
relevance to ongoing research and indeed
after many of our simulant conversations
I've found that I I I no longer use the
word mind whenever I can avoid it during
during these conversations which I
learned Bob interest in metaphysics and
its relevance of biology we decided to
in a way celebrate this book or this
this aspect of the relationship or this
area covered directly by the Frankie
program through a series of lectures
that that deal with ongoing relevant
relationship between philosophy and the
practice of biology and biological
sciences so we've got two lectures so
far by Max Bennett and Paul Griffiths
both from the University of Cindy in the
spring semester we'll continue this
series with parks by yale university
professor of ecology and evolutionary
biology and systems biology Gunter
vagner and with philosophers of biology
Alan love from university wisconsin and
peter Godfrey Smith from from cuny in in
New York so it was with great pleasure
today that ain't reduce Bob Schumann who
will speak to us about brain work and
consciousness a new paradigm
thank you very much thank you for the
opportunity to be here and to speak to
my colleagues and and like my peers
about work that we've been doing for
years can is the sound up it doesn't
sound to me like it's up well can you
hear me in the back okay good so this we
well know that this is a time of active
study and knowledge being developed
about the brain and the one double pots
played by functional imaging in this
spirit of course our publications and we
know how it's possible under visual
stimulation to find regions in the brain
that respond reproducibly and uniquely
to things like color to regions that
respond to color and other regions that
respond to lines moving to the right and
other regions that lines moving to the
left and that that's all very exciting
and I think that we all share that
excitement but that there is a counter
direct flow and there is the fact that
mmm see me there is the fact that many
people object to this imaging would you
sit down please thank you many people
object to this because we thought they'd
find that the data have been over
interpreted and all sorts of claims are
being made which are not supported by
the by the data claims for that imaging
will tell you when people are lying or
that imaging can distinguish
between the brain activity and a
Republican or a democratic voter
different regions of the brain they say
and it has been shown by several that
the the data supporting this are not
very secure they're not very
reproducible and this criticism of
functional imaging runs throughout there
are publications books books that just
save the that we have been brainwashed
and reporting these experiments which
are not really supported by the data and
that people mock these results an
English public intellectual Raymond
Tallis one of many calls it neuro trash
is live a very and the fact of the
matter is that these critics of the uses
of this imaging techniques have my
support it is correct they are right and
I'm going to tell you about the personal
experiences and therefore what i am
going to what i have to do as someone
who has participated in the development
of this field is separating out and
distinguish the differences between
those experiments which are reproducible
and reliable those experiments which
beat our scientific standards and those
experiments which somehow somehow are
being done according to different
standards and this story starts when
soon after functional imaging was
discovered by two former colleagues of
mine from Bell Labs Seiji ogawa and
Camille ogreville they came to our lab
at Yale where Doug Rothman had gotten
our magnetic resonance equipment working
so it could do functional imaging and we
did a slightly novel form of imaging a
visual stimulation which is what the
original measurements were being made up
and in that we worked with Greg McCarthy
who helped us and then when a gamma and
ooba gooba left we thought well now this
is a wonderful opportunity with this
technique to work on things like a
the mind work on mental activities so i
spoke to pat goldman rakeesha was a
neuroscientist of great repute and
wonderful person and said to a pet what
should we do in order to study the mind
how would we do it she said well you
ought to study working memory which is
short-term memory memory that you
remember for 10 seconds or so and it's
work that it would follow follow work
that she had done quite extensively on
the monkeys where she had observed but a
working memory giving nice excitation
reproducible excitation of brain regions
in the monkeys and so we set up the
experiments to do them in the human we
did the experiments we found roughly in
the where Pat heads expected we would by
analogy with the monkeys we found
activations in the frontal part of the
brain and we we published a paper which
is what you do and so though I continue
these work this work because I wanted to
see just exactly more somewhat more what
that meant and it turned out that that
this act these activations that we saw
during the comparison made of an
experiment where there was no memory
being performed and where there was that
that's what a working memory experiment
does that some of these that we not only
saw activation in the region that she
had expected but there was numerous
activations spread throughout the brain
and furthermore activation of the region
that she had picked out and that we had
published as being the source of working
memory activation there was also
achieved by many other stimuli without
any acts of remembering so there was
something obviously very wrong and what
was apparent at the time is that if
things were wrong because we were
working in a paradigm a paradigm that
came not from physics or chemistry or
even from neuro chemistry it came from
psychology and philosophy it came from
what we thought of the brain what we
thought of the brain function what we
thought of mental activities what we
thought of the mind
and so I'm quite sympathetic to the
criticisms that are being made of
working memory kinds of experiments now
20 years after because people still are
doing experiments on the cording and
basis of the paradigm that was in effect
then is still in effect it's the
paradigm called cognitive neuroscience
and I have spent these years working
with these wonderful colleagues in my
lab Doug Rothman and for meat haider and
Kenneth Kevin ba experimentally but also
reading in the philosophy and trying to
see what it was that was driving well
it's the basis that's driving these
experiments that give wrong results and
are there alternative paradigms that we
can find supported by helpfully by the
metaphysical claims of a philosophy but
which give bet the more important point
is which give better understanding and
more reliable results in a better
interpretations of the experiments then
the present paradigm does and so that
work as as rick has been has said has
been published lately and is a in this
book by called brain imaging and what
you can't see in the red there is the
point of the talk which is what it can
and cannot tell us about about
consciousness I pick consciousness as a
central issue in neuroscience and and in
psychology and I will be talking about
what it can and cannot tell us about
consciousness in today's talk and so I
propose that neuroimaging can identify
brain activity that is necessary for a
person's observable behavior and if you
get anything out of this talk get that
message which is the messages that I am
going to stick to
observables I'm going to stick to
observables of behavior and observables
of brain activity which these imaging
methods allow us to make and it is in
the connection the relationship between
these observables of brain activity and
the observables of behavior that I look
for an understanding which has the
reliable reproducible kind of result
that we find to be necessary to move
ahead in science with confidence now
this position of looking for the
parameters that I've just discussed it
differs some cognitive neuroscience
which aims to identify brain regions
responsible for mental activity that the
work on working memory which is quite
characteristic of work in the field
identifies the mental process short-term
memory working memory and then looks to
see where that process is done in the
brain I don't look to identify mental
activities and therefore I don't go
looking for them in the imaging
experiments so as an example that I will
tell you about today i plan to identify
brain activities necessary for the
person to be observably conscious rather
than starting with the definition of
consciousness so now brain functions
have been not possible to measure on the
bench top the great advances in
physiology and recent decades I've been
because the heart the kidney and the
liver and skeletal skeletal muscle can
be studied on the base on the bench top
you can profuse them with suitable
nutrients and then you can study their
function outside the body but the brain
Kenda could not be studied that way so
that the possibility of having
non-invasive neuroimaging methods now
allow us to probe brain function just as
we study activities of
other organs and that's the reason why
the imaging has been so exciting it's
not only what it can do but it's that
forth we have but we haven't been able
to do for such a long time and
neuroimaging has non-invasively
invasively measured brain energy
production in vivo and has shown that
nearly all the energy is dedicated to
the brain work of neurotransmitter
release the brain energy that is being
observed is the energy coming about from
the oxidation of glucose a very
straightforward simple process similar
of course to the oxidation of glucose
which supports a muscle or the heart and
brain activity can therefore be defined
quantitatively in terms of energy
consumed and work to form it's a
valuable valuable approach the approach
that has given us so much in
understanding today of systemic
physiology there are two methods that
I'm going to focus on there are several
others but I concentrate on to today for
simplicity and directness of exposition
and fMRI fMRI functional magnetic
resonance imaging and pet positive
positron emission tomography can
non-invasively measure human brain
activity they both can measure glucose
consumption and rate and oxygen
consumption but the fMRI can compare
brain activities in two different states
a state where a person is doing a
certain task without a memory component
and then where there is an aspect of
remembering and then the fMRI signal you
subtract the energies that you measure
in those two cases and plot the
difference and pet can study the total
or baseline energy sometimes use those
words interchangeably in any state it's
the total amount of energy that the
brain is consuming and you can do it a
distributed throughout the brain of
course
and these two brain measurements are two
parameters of neuronal activity will be
related to to measurable features of
behavior so we have two parameters in
both the behavioral and in the brain
function domain the total energy or the
baseline energy oaks are represented its
magnitude is represented by the pretty
well by the blue line and it the total
energy is to be compared with the energy
that you find measure in a fMRI
experiment it's either incremental
sometimes it's a decrement abut it the
fMRI energy is about no more than a few
percent of the total energy and so you
have to keep these magnitudes in mind
the total brain energy only a few
percent of it changes when you do n even
the most vigorous brain activity and
these separate parameters of incremental
and baseline energy will be related to
separate aspects of behavior
well to give you an example which is not
as heavily weighted by by our
preconceptions I turned to on how we
understand the muscle and to understand
the relation between brain energy
consumption and human behavior consider
how we describe muscle energy and work
the energy consumed in a muscle can be
shown to equal the work done in the the
job that we see the muscle doing the
energy of lifting a weight a certain
height is the energy there is the energy
about the glucose oxidation consumed in
that is about equal to the work done
it's a very efficient use of energy the
energy consumed that a muscle can be
shown to equal the work done in such an
activity as lifting a weight so we
sometimes say that the muscle does the
work of lifting the weight when we say
the muscle lifts the weight well this is
this description is shorthand for saying
that the muscle supports the person who
lifts the weight we understand this
error if we were to say that the muscle
work lifts the bride of course a
threshold we then correctly say in that
case that the muscle does work that
enables or supports or is necessary for
the groom to lift the bride this era is
innocuous when describing muscle but
saying that the brain does the work of
lifting ignores that is the groom not
the brain who intended is in cord in
accord with tradition to lift the bride
across the threshold the groom is a
person influenced by his culture his
religion tradition his love for the
bride the circle of family and friends
and his personal history in addition to
the many humanistic approaches for
understanding the person from the
directions that I mentioned above
neuroimaging gives us the ability to
identify necessary brain activities when
the person performs some active
in this when I did look at the paradigms
that we were using and saw how they
depended upon our assumptions about
brain and mind how they depended upon
common everyday usage of these words of
mind and mental activities I found in
philosophers several philosophers who
accepted with me the idea that there is
a difference between the person and the
brain and [ __ ] consigned in the later
years said it very well he said only of
a living human being and what resembles
or behaves like a living human being can
one say it has sensations that sees its
blinded here's Steph it is conscious or
unconscious and you know that is true
that is the proper use of language
should we look at a person we say is
conscious or e we listen to a person we
hear what he's saying we do not look at
a brain we have no way of looking at a
brain and knowing that it thinks or it
hears or it listens or it remembers or
it lays down we don't know that what we
know is that the person does these
things so in order to be a little more
specific then about the behavior and the
parameters involved let us consider the
behavioral aspects of consciousness it's
very traditional in the field to
consider two aspects of consciousness
that will be defined by observable
behavior the first is of the person
being in the state of consciousness and
the second is his performing an act of
consciousness and these same activities
have been described with different terms
by at least four different authors I
list them there
adam Zima in writing a book about
consciousness recently called a
capability of consciousness that
contents of consciousness and so on
neural correlates of consciousness says
Christof Koch and enabling door ok Carla
subconscious gets a little complicated
there and Bennett and hacker spoke about
in transitive intransitive consciousness
so but I'm going to talk about these two
behavioral aspects and the behavioral
definition of the state of consciousness
in the state of consciousness a person
is able to think or feel or move or two
side by interacting with the people in
the environment or interacting with this
environment it is objectively defined by
the person's ability to respond to
simple cognitive stimuli the
anesthesiologist measures the loss of
the state of consciousness by the
patient's inability to respond to such
stimulus stimuli under anesthesia
surgery depends upon the reliability of
this definition it is as objective a
definition of a act as we have the
behavior of a person in the state of
consciousness is clearly defined and it
could be agreed upon by the third hand
observer so I am going to show you
evidence for the statement made here
which is the title of this slide which
that's the baseline energy supports the
state of consciousness remember i define
two kinds of energies
excuse me two kinds of energies the
total or baseline energy such as is
measured by a pet experiment and then
the incremental energy which is measured
by an fMRI experiment and I propose that
to show you the data for that baseline
energy supports the state of
consciousness and here I have on the
right hand side of the slide slices of
the brain cut cut this week which show
the pet measurements of glucose
oxidation the magnitude of glucose
oxidation and the magnitude is
represented by the color and the
McCulloh goes from blue being low energy
to high being yellow and red and you see
that in the awake state the brain is has
is of this high-energy rad quite uniform
not perfectly uniform because its
variation in the gray matter but quite
uniform and high and you go to moderate
levels of anesthesia it goes it moves
down in energy and down in deep
anesthesia the activity is quite
uniformly lower and in deep anesthesia
the activity is about fifty percent of
the activity in the resting awake state
now
we now then fought the energies that we
get from these observations of the pet
in the vertical scale versus the degree
to which the patients are subjected to a
linear linear measure of the
concentration of the anaesthetic and
this is true for one anaesthetic but
it's quite been tested for quite a
number and what we see then is that if
we measure the energy as a function
linear function of the anaesthetic
concentration we get this rather
surprising a curve it's at high energy
at low anesthesia low concentration
anesthesia this high brain energy call
that a hundred percent at high
concentrations of anesthesia there's low
brain energy and between there is not a
linear dependence or not a phase change
which would be a shot change but there's
a rather sigmoid ille dependence of the
brain energy upon the level of
anesthesia at the same time it is
possible to measure the degree to which
the person is in the state of
consciousness by his ability to respond
to those simple questions and so the
overt behavior is plotted here at the on
the same normalized to the same scale
but what you see is that the overt
behavior starts the behavior is high at
low levels of anesthesia and it follows
roughly a sigmoid type curve down to
high concentrations of anesthesia where
it's reduced reduces I say to about
forty or fifty percent of the energy at
baseline and this these work came from
the work on the patients came from keto
and all in Japan and the concentrations
here came from the other authors
al-qaeda and stolen and so what we see
then is that we see that there is
is decrease in the energy that occurs as
there is this decrease in the behavior
and the the interesting one interesting
aspect of this is that the total energy
serves us as a measurable parameter
because the as I said there the the
degree of interaction between the
synapses which are firing shows that
there's a partial amount of cooperation
not the kind of total cooperation that
you would have if there were a phase
change like water freezing the ice oh
I'm not a linear change as you would get
in many other sister situations and that
gives you a way of studying the degree
of coupling of the synapses or the
neurons as they fire and we see though
that the energy is running down as the
state of consciousness runs down and we
can then take advantage of work done by
a neurologist very excellent work which
has been summarized by Lori and work
done at New York University and in
Cambridge and in Belgium where they have
measured the the amount of brain energy
consumption by pet these same kinds of
pet measurements that I shown you before
under different conditions of subjects
normal consciousness is set to a hundred
for the percentage of total energy and
then we have during deep sleep it's
around sixty percent of the total energy
a general anesthesia at surgical levels
that are used it's about 50% coma is of
the order of 50 percent and then there
is this a terrifying state locked-in
syndrome where the brainstem is still
alive but the cortex has been destroyed
and where the cortex which is where we
measure the brain activities when we
call the brain the cortex has activity
which is about equal to the resting
state but these people cannot
unless you devise ways of communicating
with them that cannot satisfy the
conditions of being in a state of
consciousness they cannot answer
questions and so what we see here for
one thing is that the total brain energy
is is necessary for the being in the
state of consciousness but it's not
sufficient you must also be able to
communicate and we also see that when
the brain energy is reduced by in these
pathological conditions or during
anesthesia that the person has comes out
of the state of consciousness so what
this says is that the human we have
defined to be in the state of
consciousness by an observable response
to simple cognitive stimuli and the high
total preparing energy provides the
support needed to keep the person in
this state of consciousness and
properties of the state of consciousness
of the state of consciousness are
extended by these measurements to
include de ronal activity by
measurements of observable brain
properties in other words one of the
things that we are interested in we are
interesting interested in what is the
person doing in the state of
consciousness and all sorts of
philosophical and psychological studies
devoted to trying to trying to define
what he is doing or trying to define
what is necessary and so but we as brain
scientists as neuro scientists want to
understand what are the properties of
this state by that are necessary for the
person to be on that say and one of the
property we have identified is the total
brain activity and from this point we
can continue to study how the state of
consciousness varies with the variation
in that parameter fluctuations so that
it's no longer perfectly uniform the
degree the magnitude when the energy is
reduced by means other than annecy
asian all these parameters are at our
disposal to study the role that the
total energy plays in the person being
in the state of consciousness so I have
defied this define the state of
consciousness by reliable behavior and
shown that high baseline energy isn't
necessary but not sufficient support he
has to be able to communicate for
example now this is not a reducing
theory of the concept of consciousness
but an understanding of an observable
behavior by measurable parameters
properties just as phenomena like
nutrition and diabetes are becoming
understood by their properties so too as
our understanding of the state of
consciousness improved by measuring the
necessary brain activities the with time
as we measure the properties of an
observable phenomena we get to
understand that better we get to be able
to define it in the 18th century water
was discovered to be composed of
hydrogen and oxygen but in soon after
hydrogen and huo became a show on a
certain pressure and temperature
intervals became the definition of water
so as we measure the properties of
biological phenomena complicated
phenomena as we measure the properties
our understanding grows our
understanding grows by understanding the
properties and we create and the
mechanisms by which the sitch the system
reaches its state we when we sought when
we do biology we do not plan to define a
tree by the Acorn we do not have an
acorn and reducing laws which if
followed would produce a tree from that
a chord what we have is a tree and we
know tia logically that it will produce
a day we haven't treated and eco and
will produce the tree under certain
circumstances and we study the
mechanisms and the properties that are
necessary for that akon to become the
tree and those are the same kind
of properties that I am presenting to
you here as properties of the person in
the state of conscious building up an
understanding we'd Harry now to the
second acts of consciousness and it's a
precondition that enables the person to
perform the acts of consciousness and in
an act of consciousness the person
performs a behavior that requires
knowledge and recognizing a face or a
similar object like the bird or car is
an act of consciousness that requires
the person to reproducibly distinguish
many factors an fMRI signals from a rain
region when a person recognizes the face
or Berea color reflects rain support
during an act of consciousness now so we
can confidently decide when a person is
performing an act of consciousness my
observable behavior the fMRI signal
measures the differences in neuronal
energies that support the person in
performing these acts of consciously as
the measurement we get the measurement
of the neuronal differences so I propose
that when a person learns to
reproducibly understand a comparison
becoming an expert his brain expertise
also becomes reproducible and when some
does usually done the fMRI signal will
be stronger and readily distinguished
this follows my assumption that the
brain response follows the person's
decision other experiments that can test
the hypothesis that brain responses
become more reproducible when a person's
act of consciousness becomes clearer and
more reproducible better understood /
the fusiform face area is a region in
the visual cortex that responds to the
site of faces and other objects I'm
going to show you how learning to
recognize objects creates this
modularity or creates strong signals in
the free fusiform face area the region
is conveniently located by mapping the
difference fMRI so
no between the person viewing faces
right side up and reviewing inverted
faces it was first shown here by Greg
McCarthy and his colleagues that this
region exists that following that Isabel
Gotye here at Yale at the time showed
that learning to identify novel head
like objects little doll like objects
called greebles created an fMRI signal
in the at region that previously could
not be identified so this now will be a
test of could a person distinguished at
first person cannot distinguish between
weebles these objects then after he has
learned to this distinguish we will find
that we will ask the question and
finally answer as to whether then is a
region clear region a reproducible
corresponding to the reproducible
response that he has learned to have to
these greebles so here are the greebles
you don't have to pay any attention to
them except to recognize that they are
somewhat difference is the fact one the
sinner this has sort of eyebrows that
doesn't end so on so you can understand
that with by paying attention to certain
you can tell the difference between
these object you could say fact within
and when you see the cerebral upside
down you will recognize that it is a you
recognize that green he's that he's the
fat guy so here's a kind of result i
can't give you it i try to protect you
from seeing fMRI scans I mean the true
scans the actual data not the stuff that
people publish the data that Gotye at
all published and just take you to the
very simple part of it here are the
responses that include this FF a region
of people who are novices with these
spectacles and here the responses of
people who are experts after they've
been through some training sessions and
if you look at the comparative signal of
faces right side up versus upside down
you see that this particular region
outlined in the square has an activation
right in the red yellow region which as
you may remember is
found a high activation their
activations throughout the brain we're
just not dealing with them right now on
the other hand when the people in this
test looking at the Greenville's right
side up and right side down then in that
there's no reproducible activation in
that region outlined by the square but
not not containing any activation well
on the other hand if we go to the people
who have learned to distinguish
Greenville's they have the same act
similar activation when they have face
of faces being compared right side up
and right and right side down but they
also can tell the gets an activation
when the Greenville's are compared right
side up and right side down and then we
can see that the magnitude of these
given here when we start after one or
two chefs sessions of teaching this
cohort of six untrained people to
recognize the people that the magnitude
of the signal represents by its
probability of being of not being
probably of not being random the back
degree of the signal of the Greenville's
is small compared to the magnitude that
they get in the faces like I showed you
in the previous images but with time and
with practice the magnitude when the in
the grievance experiment approaches the
magnitude of the face experiment in
other words if we looked at a people who
are looking at greebles we what we see
is that the reproducibility the
understanding the knowledge that this
greevil difference for that one has
enabled us to get a reproducible signal
in the brain in a nice in a nice
reproducible way and this these
experiments show that a reproducible
brain responds to a comparison is
created when a person learns to
reproducibly distinguish the objects
being compared hooble and weasel amongst
others showed that the reproducibility
of brain responses to sensory
stimulation was strongly dependent on
the animals
experience are particularly early
childhood experiences result in complete
confusion if they are confusing it
confuse that in the early years and the
dependence of brain responses on
expertise suggests that higher-order
concepts like memory or attention or
patriotism or voting democratic do not
create reproducible strong fMRI signals
they don't because the person's
understanding of such concepts is not
reproducible in other words if they
understanding of memory or attention or
of love is context dependent and depends
upon the history of the person the
subject which is expressing the task
which is expressing that concept and the
reason why then we do not get clean
sharply defined reproducible activations
of the brain when these higher-order
concepts of being studying and the
reason why considerable confusion
develops throughout the field when
people pick out an activation say this
is memory or this is short-term memory
is that these these concepts when you go
looking for them as cognitive
neuroscience does these concepts are
dependent upon the context in which they
exist this is a this is an important
philosophical point I mean is there such
a point as it is there an innate
understanding of memory or there's
memory an ability that we have developed
from experience the hope that fMRI will
give reproducible localized brain
responses to higher order terms like
memory or distinguish between
Republicans and Democrats fails because
terms are uncertain with meanings that
vary with context because brain activity
follows the person's understanding fmri
cannot identify concepts better than the
person can so that the paradigm of
looking in the brain to clarify a
definition to finally nail down des
cartes concepts of mind is intrinsically
impossible and therefore you get much
muddy results and people select the data
or over interpret it if you want and
claim that they have found these elusive
subjective concepts it is the hope it is
a great hope but it is not to be
realized and because brain activity
follows the person's understanding fMRI
cannot identify concepts better than the
person can so once again I I find
support at toward these ideas in the
Philosopher's I mean I'm a scientist I'm
not a philosopher but I find more
support in various philosophers for the
ideas that I am Telling You then I find
in my scientific colleagues because I
take you to back to William James who
defined the subject philosophical
subject of pragmatism and spoke about
how it dealt with concepts and his words
themselves give you a sort of the same
that give you the spirit of what his
conclusions are so the University says
has always appeared to the natural mind
as a kind of enigma of which the key
must be sought in the shape of an
illuminating or power bringing word or
name and that word names the universe's
principle and to possess it is after a
fashion to possess the universe itself
God matter reason the absolute energy
are so many solving names you can rest
when you have them you are at the end of
your metaphysical quest but if you
follow the pragmatic method which is
what he advises you cannot look on any
such word as closing your quest you must
bring out of each word it's practical
cash value see it at work within the
stream of your experience it appears
less as a solution that has a program
for more work quote from this book on
pragmatism so brain support of the
person's observable behavior will
pretend upon the individuals history its
culture and the immediate context this
difference of cognitive neuroscience
again which assumes the brain recognizes
mental
and looks for activity induced by terms
like memory intent or free will that are
independent of context there will always
be found in the same Varian region give
a shot signal hypotheses about
psychological interpretation of behavior
require a structure that allows for
individual differences board riser and I
proposed and that the high brain
activity supporting the state of
consciousness could provide the energy
for Freud's many layers of the
unconscious that was a proposal about of
a psychology that we talk more about in
a moment Freudian psychology amongst
others could provide a structural
interpretation of an individual's
history relating brain activities to
behavior this again is in contrast to
the psychology that I've been
criticizing of cognitive psychology it
is a psychology that has to take into
account the individuals distinctive
history and at the same time provide you
with a structure for studying it so that
for example take a crude approximation
of what a Freudian view might be the
person invariably has strong relations
with his or her mother so that if you
design test to hype based upon that
hypothesis of making comparisons if you
want to test that psychology or another
psychology you would then have that
proposed as hypotheses and do
experiments comparing a state of
relationship with not and see what brain
activities give you and are they are
they reproducible indicating that this
is a actually a fairly reproducible and
clear understanding of that
psychological state that's the way to
study these like these hypotheses
introduced by psychology rather than
just assuming as cognitive neuroscience
does that cognitive psychology works so
in conclusion brain activity by
supporting the individuals actions in
the state and acts of consciousness is
an evolutionary success in that dap
tation like the opposable thumb we have
generally proposes everything
supports that nap tation but we shown
the mechanism by which these different
activities support the adaptation and
consciousness in contrast to the brains
control of behaviors assumed by
cognitive neuroscience I've shown how
brain activity serves to support not to
control the person's behavior learning
in the grievance experiment was done by
the person not by the brain our paradigm
expects reproducible fMRI responses too
familiar sensory task but differs from
cognitive science by explaining fMRI
failures to find reproducible responses
to postulated mental concepts we seek
brain activity necessary for an
individual's behavior we do not seek
brain activities that could provide
objective definitions of subjective
mental concepts I think that is the
point that I wanted to make and I make
the point of course that experiments
that I have shown you they certainly
even if they're a semi infinite number
of them would not prove that the point
that I'm making these experiments
illustrate the kinds of interpretations
that one would make of the data if one
is assumed basically this metaphysical
position and what I'm showing is that
and it's examples I've given you quite
illustrative of the state of the field I
mean these I did these are not a typical
examples where I pick out this kind of
greebles experiment throughout the field
you find data that that I've given you a
summary of necessarily a summary of and
short talk but what we find is that the
methods I have proposed of thinking of
the brain supporting the person not
controlling person worked very well in
interpreting the data and do not lead to
the kind of foolish conclusions that are
bound in the popular press and so let's
hope that other people like that thank
I don't know if I really need this but
one of the things that is striking about
the anesthesia experiment is the
sigmoidal character of the data which
correlate consciousness as represented
by responsive atif to brain overall
brain activity and ordinarily what we
understand in our science is that such
behavior implies a cooperativity among
regions and so that one would anticipate
some sort of interactive principle not
just a point-by-point change in energy
but that the interactions among those
points would be of great consequence how
do you think of that in terms of your
acts consciousness that is the
distribution of interactions that govern
the acts that you are trying to
characterize by activities right in the
MRI yes that's good that's bit pushy the
acts of consciousness are supported by
an innumerable amount of interactions
that we cannot describe in finding the
curvature of the total energy in the
state of consciousness we have the
ability to parameterize that in terms of
maybes two parameters the strength of
the coupling between two synapses and
the number of couplings that it takes to
fire I'll give you that and then fitting
that to the shape of the curve
would be building a bottom-up
understanding of the complexity of
interaction but based upon the data that
we have would we reach the complexity of
Noah but that's it that's pleasures of
being human one notices though that
there are many responsive areas in
addition to the ones that were boxed in
the images that you show and it's those
interactions yeah I guess that I'm
asking yeah certainly the what this
leads one to do and this is actively
being done at the field of course when I
say that the difference in the brain
activity an fMRI experiment supports the
acts of consciousness we want to know
more and more and more about what we are
measuring in in those energy that the
localization of it the intensity of it I
could go on a great deal because that is
the state of the field now to a great
extent that it is devoted to
understanding physical neuroscience so
yes one wats understand is what it's
going on
be here is it fair to say the bombs hold
on that isn't illegible why not settle
for anything but getting your teeth on
some real good hard facts out of this
pile of Durham trash maybe some people
would call it and we thank you for that
because you pulled out about some things
that we can canal you build Oh
presumably so my question follows on the
previous one in the sense of wondering
now that you use the comparison the
filling of the space between the Acorn
and the oak tree and that there are
presumably multiple steps there and in
your work on consciousness you've taken
one step it seems in that process from
the brain to consciousness I'm wondering
from your vantage point of having
thought this through so much could you
give us any advice about the future
directions I mean how should we pursue
now to fill up more of the space between
the Acorn and the and the oak tree yeah
give you some examples of kinds of
experiments being done the medial temple
load the hippocampus is known to be
necessary for long-term memory
declarative memory if it's damaged
people can't remember things from the
past that happened to them when people
study by fMRI the acts of remembering
what they find is no activation of the
of that region during the acts of
remembering or recalling so it's not
necessary for the acts of remembering
but it is necessary to have that region
operative in order for the person to
remember but what they do find in
meta-analysis that Todd constable and
judge Meltzer have made published a few
years ago in a meta-analysis of all the
data in the
feel is that psychologists have found
something we really rather know that
when a person is finds an act an action
to be a novel or fitting into with their
novel or else fits in with their
previous legally they are understanding
either of those conditions a person
remembers this thing very well you
remember things that fit in with your
preconceptions basically well that are
novel and exciting and what they find is
that there are activations during the
remembering say say during a novel
process in regions of the brain that
roughly corresponds to the the reaction
to novelty in the prefrontal cortex
actually and so what we see there is
that the brain responses to the person
are illuminating the mechanisms involved
in the person remembering although it's
not them remembering if not memory a
concept it's what the person has brought
to it and that he finds this kind of
particular task novel and that brain is
showing that novelty so bringing up
brain activities which elucidate the
complexity of the person's response is
really marvelous in and should be you
don't want to look then for what the
cognitive neuroscientist looks for where
is that cognitive response to the memory
act no it's what is it that the person
has that is making his remembering work
so well and that's sort of following up
of the aux auxiliary activities in a
behavior that you are not defined by the
reduction of the the behavior to a
concept
you had a very large sample of images of
a person awake and the same person
asleep do you think that you could
distinguish one set of data from the
other say this is the waking set of
images and this is the sleep set of
images well it is interesting that when
people do fMRI experiments on sleep and
compared with the way in deep sleep the
one where there was a 50-percent only
fifty percent of the total activity in
deep sleep there is not much activity in
the cortex not much whereas when people
are in rapid eye movement sleep where
they are obviously dreaming and thinking
a lot the cortex lights up lots of
activities all over the place quite
there so that if I were asked to tell
the difference in answer to your
question between slow-wave sleep a deep
sleep and awake yes I could I could say
that looks like it could be slow wave
sleep or it could be anesthesia too but
the difference is between rapid eye
movement sleep and awake are not
revealed by the fMRI signals tell the
difference between a series of images of
a person alive and dead poke sure you
could good
what question over there it would be hi
thank you so much for your talk um I
just have a quick question about what
you mean when you say that the person is
doing the learning and not the brain or
that the person is controlling their
behavior not the brain are you saying
the person is like could you talk louder
and slow sure so what do you mean
exactly when you say that a person is
doing the learning in for example the
greebles experiment and not the brain or
that the person is controlling the
behavior and not the brain is the person
like some non physical entity yours fMRI
just not good enough technology to
measure the person yeah that actually
course the question comes up often
particularly asked by my scientific
colleagues they say I know what you mean
by this or that technical term but what
do you mean by person and well that
though is exactly the point the reason
the thing that we're interested in is
answering that question what is the
person and what do we mean by what is
the person well in the case that I'm
pointing to one of the person's
attributes what is the person nor does a
person know how does the how does the
person distinguish between two different
phenomena and what I'm saying is that
the person we can identify his behavior
of understanding those those differences
but now we have extending our
understanding of what the person means
beyond his social security number and
his driver's license and as you know and
all the things that we know about him is
his views on culture and his sense of
and sense of personal relations we're
extending that view of what the person
is buy these additional properties of
how his brain is responding to the
different activities that he does
physical thing that's changing in order
to learn whatever like that how do
distinguish greebles or is it something
non-physical that's changing about if I
understand your question is is is what
we learn physical and non-physical the
only thing we learned is physical we
have physical scientists right but
that's different than the brain I just
some cannot use it's different from what
but so but that physical change isn't
happening in the brain or I'm just that
difference as we I can't get week when
we come to these subjective concepts of
that we use to describe ourselves in
everyday life I I'm not proposing to
give you a definitive answer at all okay
what I'm saying is that instead of
saying we understand that there that the
person is doing memory at this time we
under we see it an activity where the
person is remembering something okay and
then we when that person remembers
things sigh we study how people remember
that is how people learn that's what
education is about theories of education
how people are in all that stuff okay
I'm saying that what we add to that is
something about the brain activity and
one thing we add which is of
significance for learning and education
as I say that we do not have innate
understandings I go along with all the
wonderful experiments that have been
done hubo and weasel I mentioned and
Bruce Wexler elaborates upon his
wonderful book that the we learn by
experience to understand thats why we go
to school
you